winning the oscar really was about
knowing
all of the all the feelings and
intentions and all the hard work and
everything that came to
together to make this piece it was
really validated
we felt like we did everything we had to
do and it's like at that point
you know it's like if it happens it
happens but you feel like you've
really done all the work that you can do
and the oscar goes to
hair love matthew h
i don't remember how we got on the stage
we somehow got there
just magically um it was all just a
dream you know so that's why it's a
little strange to see that it actually
happened
you dream about a moment like that all
your life when you're up there
you're literally looking at a crowd of i
forget how many thousand people were
there
and then you have the big teleprompter
right in front of you basically with a
countdown
you know it can be really hard to gather
your thoughts
thank you so much to the academy and
everybody out there that supported this
film there were lots of you
we share this award with you being there
and being in the in this room
you know this room that we'd always
dreamed of with like all of our idols
and you know actors and the best
performers and directors and producers
that in itself was surreal
so i just want to say that hair love was
done because we wanted to see more
representation in animation
there were so many filmmakers that
worked so hard on this and it was a
labor of love
and it was because we have a firm belief
that representation matters deeply
as a child it's the first images that we
see we're always watching tv cartoons
and watching animated movies and
you know as a black kid you know we're
very aware of the fact that there are no
images that look like us you know we
grew up without them and that was really
profound and it shaped us you know in a
way that you don't want to have to have
kids not be able to see themselves
on the screen especially in cartoons
because in cartoons that's when we first
see our movies and it's how
we shape our lives and think about how
we see the world even though these
characters in our short film were black
there's just something about the medium
that
really i think just makes people a
little bit more open to
exploring these worlds that are a little
bit more either fantastical or
worlds that aren't what their normal
experience is i have to do something
just as good so i can get back there and
you know
they can thank them again i'm just
excited about using that energy
taking it to go make other things with
that same kind of passion
and i think that's the main thing that
no one can take that away from me i know
exactly how that feels and i want to
feel it i want to feel it again
you